good afternoon everyone and my name is
senior and I was a a banana before I
come to us and after I came to years.i I
try to avoid anything related to
technology because I don't
I almost feel that my programming cause
when I was encouraging China but
unfortunately for any mass of arts even
massive arts in geography our department
required me to take an introduction to
GIS cause I was very reluctant them to
take their course
yesterday I checked my transcript I got
a b-minus and I got a message from
graduate school saying if you continue
to perform like this we will take as a
graduate assistantship from you so it
was amazing it's really amazing is
nowadays I teach you all the difficult
difficult the course is in my department
and a kind of State I teach Childers
special program all these costs I did
not dare to take when I was a math
student so why I got involved in the
like the GS computing especially
nowadays in I work with computer science
faculty is getting too big NSF grants
all about it big big social data so I
have some good experience to show is how
the open source like it's an open source
movement it totally changed in my life
how to move me from a person who really
try to get hands off the older technical
issues from this kind of person to come
into a like kind of way to work with all
these chemical science faculty and the
ways many I have many research
assistants also from stats so I had big
my research is very much from the at the
beginning especially inequality and
sustainability very much Human Geography
and economic geography when I did my
first master's degree I realized how
amazing when you brought all the so
economic value was on the map so I try
to say okay I want to learn some GS
function I want to click the button
later I find out if I click the button
it means my research will be to driven
instead of a research question even very
luckily I met quite a few fantastic
scholars who are both a human geographer
and also an open-source a computer
scientists so the guy didn't mean saying
hey no difficult that no difficult just
follow other people the codes modify
that and understand a logic
it's amazing only taking me I mean one
semester to switch the from a person who
very kind of feared of all these kind of
technical issues into a person who love
testing research questions using the
open-source code later after I became
faculty and for the sake of the money I
looking to the big social data and I
realized the big social data all the
things that looking to social media
crime data to charity that they
documented reminded me of my previous
background in specially inequality and
sustainability
so then I integrate my expertise on open
source computing and my previous the
theoretical thinking so together so for
my current research and I ran a very
successful lab and I can state the
University so theoretical theoretically
we need a space-time is the joint
thinking of space-time allow us to tap
into many possibilities of public policy
and therefore methodologically
definitely interesting thing is the
challenging things to couple the spatial
temporal attributes of the socio
economic dynamics regarding for for
nowadays we have many different way to
define yes I think more recently is a
more mixed definition system science
service studies now for many futures of
GS
but for oven yes I have
some clever collaborative work with
Daniel say from Ohio State that we are
looking to the eighth dimension so for
the open data
I think elects me or mentioned that and
so later I will give more in detail
explanation of my working open software
now I will skip there and never open
hard work for the thing crying the
fetter server today I just submitted a
second proposal with some computer
engineering about the frying de Jonge to
monitor the real-time urban dynamics so
this is more like how do we integrate
the hardware and software the open
standards because for sure we if we
develop a software hardware we need a
some standard and open open
collaboration
it's Chuy's not nowadays if you apply
grunts it's better to have people from
different disciplines and across
different universe they do share the
results for the open collaborations we
we are also looking to the from space
who space to praise called a cognitive
transition and a computational one from
analysis more like a synthesis is a more
like a diffusion to relate a different
data source is looking to the
heterogeneous data source is a fusion
when we look at all the brightenings of
the open source movement
the only other backside that critical
thinking is looking at digital divide
the privacy human rights and all this
and also for the open publications and
everyone like money is the open funding
so the MOC system the open education
open learning to to generally to change
the next generation
researchers and educators so so that's
in
I will very much focus on the open G as
the second component I said in the
component of open G as it's about open
soft world these are two important
open source packages I have been getting
involved in the left-side stars is
space-time analysis of original system I
was only research assistant for this and
as ever found in the project when I was
in California doing my PhD and later
since stars the folks on both the
utilization and analysis of space-time
data the develop team later decided it's
too stressful to focus on both how about
we focus on one because there are so
many visualization packages or interface
so if beta will focus on only on
computing so that's there's a pycelle I
think that Python now released every
half a month no every half a year so you
go can go check online hosted in Arizona
State University and my television
Advisors a jewelry and for me is that we
the wonder is when I look at attribute I
like to look at a word it is in the
spatial structure and words located in
statistical distribution and how what is
located in the temporal chance so I when
I develop my mother's I always do it
from but if a framework thought is
looking to okay if I can bind spatial
and temporal dimensions then I look at
each dimension for skills for skills
from individual to global and if I look
at a pick up any self focus my local
special special local spatial structure
global I mean over time in the mean then
I can pretty much look at different
socio-economic system from the like more
like the bottom maps is your similarity
across time over time
lisa paths on the top look at like the
yellow ones and we present the 48 states
in us and the blue one the china's like
province so they were china is more like
have divided regional system than us and
not only that we work with the
Department of Commerce to help them to
so that's another way of open data if
the data is opened but everything in the
PDF how many of you really spend time
with hundreds or thousands of pages of
PDF so we worked with the department
commerce before there was that one
notice is a larger layoff we developed
some codes to convert PDF to CSV at a
time and do the error debugging and view
that they have from different
perspective it's not in any years i soft
words totally in python and some very
recent exciting work in the past
academic year a guard who large NSF
grants both of them from NSF and I will
cream ADA for my transition I moved from
socio-economic and nameks into I call
human dynamics because these two are
very much looking to the individual data
the first is social media social network
look at how how the message is diffuse
on the network and how the virtual and
real space interact with each other and
the second one is a look at individual
vehicles how they move in the street and
network and well I look at all of them
then help me to understand as a chance
of partition network on one side on the
other side helping me to understand how
the urban area is organized so now we
are allowed due to the data availability
we can understand our human dynamics all
the way from genetic to the word wide
and for this is September 11 F
September 14th we have got a kind of the
initiative from White House asking for
the smart cities and the for the smart
cities we do have some gravities in my
NSF grants we will continue to apply for
smart city new day theater projects but
in my this is just published in I think
I drank the the top three it's a
Calcutta communication research yes
communication research general we are
looking to the social media to
understand the network structure and the
community community evolution uses -
hai-yah example on Twitter
and we look at that based on this is a
traditional and its analysis from
communication theory but why did all
these tweeters identify this network
look at her over time it's a 1 T is for
2 weeks
ta 3 months after the disaster we find
beautiful we found out that it's a
highly curated network is a highly
curated in the community network and
also for the taxi movement we are
looking to the taxi using China's
sensing example and each day we got
about I think the 60 million samples we
have collected a for several months and
for that we are building the topic of
modeling about that huge amounts of each
edge of the data so you can naturally
divide us engine into different region
otherwise it it cannot be it's not
doable without building these all the
individual trajectories and save them in
the graph database so we can also look
at by the taxi to geometry whether it's
a vacant or occupied we can divide the
city structure dynamically over hours
bios so this is how I benefit from all
this is starting
my god did my PhD God don't you think
the patient researching woman that is a
small amount man say 1500 but I might
have I said hey in the future we'll get
along so now don't apply too much 1500
to build up a framework then then I
always move doing to the difference with
work with Department Commerce Department
energy NSF and from socio economic
dynamics to human dynamics so that's my
way of doing the research then I want to
add more titles I do research it very
much from lab style but I won't make the
social economic research II to be very
fundable and recently I really want to
ask more money to lose the crab erosion
across borders I my reason the grounds I
count as a how many disciplines got
involved work with cameo science with
the public health that in the same
ground where can be science engineering
civil engineering communication and
predict Oh science yes pretty much yes
so we will get more discipline in the
involved thank you